I mean come on sometimes she's
fundamental
[Applause]
[Music]
classic Doctor Who review time and as
voted on by my wonderful supporters over
on patreon go check it out lots of
things you can get there
yeah I'll plug it again at the tail end
you think I'd not do it cuz I did it at
the front but yeah I am I'm gonna shill
but I'm doing it for me but anyway as my
patron Iser selected it's time for not
only a first doctor story but a pretty
well regard to one as well and that is
the time meddler so this is another one
that I have seen before but have not
seen in quite a while so couple things
about this this is the last episode of
the second season of the array of the
original run of the show so this is kind
of tail end ish for for William
Hartnell's
run he you know he had season 3 after
this but basically the decision would
have been made somewhat after this would
have been shot to have the next one be
his last season I don't know exactly how
the timing worked out it maybe it
happened during the shooting in the next
season but this is a case we're watching
this episode you can see why they would
have felt that was necessary and that's
something that I'll come back to mom but
in any case we have the doctor and he
lands in Northumbria with two companions
who I'm actually not familiar with
outside of the story of Vicky and Steven
and this is Stevens first trip actually
in the TARDIS dad to the point that he
actually does not believe that it is a
time machine he spends the first two
complete episodes it's not until the
third out of four episodes that he
finally Mets yeah okay it's a time
machine
but anyway they land there and this is
sort of right on the cusp of of a Viking
invasion and like this is a major point
in history and again they sort of
betrays the early intentions of Doctor
Who to be a more flatly educational
program as there are a number of points
where characters the
Derr usually just sort of stops and lays
out oh yes
yes this is about to happen and that
results in this and this oh yes it's
very interesting um and since I
mentioned sort of Hartnell's performance
there I'll say that he is a lot more
lovable in this then then he was you
know earlier in the run of the show he's
a lot more mischievous he's a lot more
kind of joyous in what he does he seems
to be having more fun he's still he's
still a bit grumpy anyway they get there
and you know they're just kind of
exploring about because I at this point
the doctor really can't control where
the TARDIS lands at all so they're just
sort of seeing what's going on and
there's a monastery and you know there's
a village that they kind of but there's
a monastery up on the hill and there's a
monk supposedly there's a whole bunch of
them you know people here Gregorian
chants sort of coming down maybe as a
Gregorian I'm not gonna look up what
kind of chanting or whatever but they
they hear those those chants come down
and they say oh there's a bunch of monks
up there well no it's just the one and
he's got a recording of monks singing
and he is luring the Viking fleet to
land here as opposed to where there's
some historically supposed land and then
intending to wipe them all out in order
to alter the course of history so the
the monk who is never identified as
anything other than a time meddler or
just the monk and he's sort of known you
in fandom circles at this point has the
meddling monk and he is a Time Lord
they're not called Time Lords yet that
name doesn't get said until Troutman's
time but it is acknowledged that he is
from the same place that the doctor came
from actually from the doctors future he
says that the monk is from about 50
years forward in in time from when he
comes from and the doctor while he is
did to a minute is is very clear that he
understands that this guy's got a better
TARDIS than he has so the doctor
obviously puts his foot down is I'm not
going to let you do this and then you
know we we go from there
now I do in some ways I'm kind of
spoiling a bit because some of the stuff
that I talked about doesn't really get
revealed until like Episode three you
know and it was stuff that was obviously
meant to be a gradual reveal you know
like something's off with the month but
the thing is at this point not only is
the story so well known but like any
basic like just pitch synopsis mentions
the fact that the that the monk is a
time traveler so even though the
original intention for be watching for
the first time is that you wouldn't know
that I think pretty much at this point
everybody does so what have we got going
on here well we've got these new
companions and they're decent especially
Steven for a first outing you know he's
got that sort of well I know what's
going on around here but you know he can
also admit when he's wrong eventually
he's a little bit condescending to Vicki
and Vicki is for the most part a little
bit more clever than him he doesn't seem
to recognize that the doctor as I said
is very enjoyable in this he's got he's
got that twinkle in his eye going a bit
more at this point but as I mentioned it
is it is pretty clear that they were
really having to work around Hartnell's
physical and mental condition at this
point because there's you know there's
long stretches where he doesn't appear
he doesn't appear in the second episode
of all like we hear his voice but he
doesn't appear in that episode and
there's a fair number of points in
scenes where it's very clear that the
other actors are if not directly feeding
him lines prompting him probably more
than this than the script would normally
call for you know in the way that I mean
if you've ever seen someone if you ever
seen improv acting exercises the way
someone might try and and lead someone
down down a certain story kind of like
oh you mean this thing and the doctor
like yes he says that and like he'll add
a little bit more but it's very clear
that he's not he's not retaining the
information and he's needing these extra
promptings and it's making some of the
dialogue and some of the scenes a little
awkward a little repetitive a little
redundant and it is a shame because as I
said you can tell he's having more fun
with the part than he was when it
started but it's it's hard to argue that
it wasn't the right call to to replace
him after the following season cuz you
you can really start to see the issues
it's not just like one flubbed word or
one sort of you know he misses like a
little bit or repeats part of a line
while he's saying it like it happens a
lot in this story and it's it's kind of
sad in a way the monk is is actually
family interesting character and it's
he's also one of those characters that
classic who fans have a tendency to go
why is that character never come back
and honestly I'm not entirely sure why I
I think he's he's interesting as a rogue
Time Lord because as far as the world
Time Lords go like he's basically one of
four that we know much about because
there's the doctor obviously I mean you
could count Suzan I suppose but there's
effectively there's the doctor the
master the Rani and the monk and they
all kind of have slightly different
ammos and what I like about the monk is
that he does seem to at least claim and
possibly even believe some sort of
altruistic purpose behind what he's
doing you know saying how he if he does
this and this person gets to rule
instead of who history says was supposed
to then all this other stuff will be
prevented all these good things will
happen he's improving history or that's
his argument
and while the episode doesn't draw
attention to this like I call BS on that
but not in a like I'm saying this to
hide my true intentions way but in like
I think this guy's fooling himself
because his TARDIS is full of all these
artifacts
he's just been collecting stuff that he
thinks is cool and fun and he talks
about how he has fun doing this I think
he is rationalized you know oh well I do
it for the greater good or he does it
because he wants to he does it because
he enjoys it he does because he gets
cool souvenirs but he has
rationalizations for why he does what he
does and he's buying into them pretty
decently and I think that makes for a
actually surprisingly developed
character the rest of the supporting
cast is solid as far as the the Vikings
and the Saxons and and and all that
they're fine they're fairly stock for
what we've gotten especially a lot in a
lot of these early seasons of Doctor Who
in terms of you know the the village you
know the the sort of natives of the time
and you know be there's always someone
who's like really skeptical I don't
trust these outsiders and you know
there's a there's a little power
struggle there's that you know it's it's
functional is what it is it's not
particularly exceptional the fights were
actually surprisingly harsh not that
they were actually like well
choreographed fights because they
weren't but you know it's like with axes
and swords and these people are dead
after they fight a lot of times so that
was kind of surprising and it does look
good as is true as of I think most
black-and-white Doctor Who it looks good
and I mentioned this before black and
white covers a lot of sins and when you
don't have to match colors or or account
for for things like that and you you
it's just a lot more forgiving
the money that they had to make the show
with stretches a little bit farther and
makes it a little bit more believable I
think back in the black and white days
than it was once I went to color so I'll
talk a little bit about the very end and
this would constitute a proper like a
real legitimate spoiler so if you
haven't seen this before and you care
check it out I do recommend it so I
really do like the way that the doctor
strands the the monk and the thing is he
does strand him I was gonna say defeats
the monk but you know he defeats him
just by ensuring he doesn't get to do
what he pulled off but he goes to step
farther he's like no I'm not gonna let
this guy do anything like this ever
again and he disables I forget exactly
what the monk calls us something about
the interdimensional something-or-other
technobabble thing of the ship so that
when the monk like tries to get back
inside because it's a small entrance but
you get inside then you can stand up cuz
it's bigger on the inside he tries to
get inside and it's the inside is now
the size that it would be forgiven how
small the outer shell is TARDIS is
currently appearing the doctor broke the
bigger on the inside bit and that's
actually something that's kind of been
revisited in New Era Doctor Who like in
name of the doctor the the doctors
TARDIS without the doctor you're slowly
dying just keeps getting bigger and
bigger and bigger because the bigger on
the inside is leaking out what the
doctor does to the monk's TARDIS is kind
of the inverse of that just shrink the
the inside down to the size that would
have to be to fit in what the outer
shell is and I think that's a pretty
pretty clever way to do it in terms of
defeating this guy making sure he can't
do anything worse but you know also just
you have the means to continue to live
this isn't a death sentence for you but
no traveling days are done buddy so I
think that's that's about it it's it's a
pretty breezy for part er there's
actually there's not nearly as much so
plot and story as I would have thought
to it but Hartnell despite his you know
very clearly deteriorating ability to
keep up is really on point in the
performance so it is still worth seeing
and the monk is good you know the plots
pretty just basic as far as these sort
of historical things go you know
preserve history we got to be sure it
happens the way that it's supposed to
but that this was sort of the first like
major wrinkle like this in the
historical stories I think as opposed to
them just being straight historical I
say I think because every time I say
that about a classic who would like
actually it was this episode because I
don't do research we'll wrap it up there
the meddling monk whose good to revisit
I like this one so what do you think of
it if you've seen it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff to do buttons links I mentioned
the patreon I'm mentioning it again
every bit of support helps but there's
other stuff to check out down there as
well give it a look if you feel like it
and if you don't that is okay because at
the end of the day you're the council
and I am just running the meetings until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]